[Music]
um it's been a it's it's been a long
time I shouldn't have left you without
some new dating to step two step two
step two remember Dayton's dad's dying
Dayton hypernova's dad's dying
um
so
my dad asked me to get him a blank this
is from his Facebook and then I'm gonna
play his video just so we get a little
update uh a little background here my
dad asked me to get him a blanket from
his recliner chair downstairs the only
time he's spoken to me this week since
being home I finally found one and took
it to him and the moment I entered the
room the stench was beyond anything I
have a fairly strong stomach at the bad
stenches but it was definitely an instag
reflex all my bigot skin head enabler
relatives when they're not around and
have to endure that it's not an ordinary
old person smell it's weeks in the
hospital cancer patient type smell
Karma
I'm I'll show it to you or karmic you
know same thing
your dad's dying of cancer
I'm not gonna put I can't put the
screenshot up because there's other
people that are innocent in it but what
a piece of [ __ ] man this is how I
[ __ ] hate this guy
then he said the last time I was paid
was four weeks ago
uh before Halloween remember maybe his
parents are not giving him his allowance
because his dad is
dying of cancer
my Mom owes me four weeks of pain
there's no way she's going to pay a
queer trans person that close to 500
when my existence is against her
pro-trump views these are shitty uh
shitty bigots and my dad is listening to
Trump's new campaign for presidency
downstairs loudly his dad who
has cancer in between listening to Bob
Dylan CCR Rolling Stones I mean it's
pretty cool what's the problem so dad
likes old rock who cares oh but it's all
the liberal music Nixon hated when he
was doing [ __ ] okay shut up and you know
I'm sure you know about Nixon so
you see this note that you see there he
left this note
on his parents refrigerator he didn't
say it to them but what he did was grab
his [ __ ] phone and do this
I'm keeping this on record right now how
much my mom is our employer record for
who who's the record for you basically
almost got your parents in trouble
because they've been a lot they were
they were kind of working the system
which by the way a lot of people do this
to try to help you out and you call them
out for being tax frauds
you're trying to get them [ __ ]
federal prison over this because they're
basically trying to make it so you can
still get government insurance
actually paid me for the month of uh
November between well between the last
week of
October that you didn't pay me and the
following three weeks this is the end of
the third week up um
this is the end of the third week
uh you ever wish cancer was contagious
or whatever anyway it's been four weeks
in total that she did not pay me so she
owes me four hundred dollars and I'm
counting it right now how much he
actually
and I knew she wasn't going to pay me
exactly right because she never does
she's selfish with her money and she
she's selfish he's living in her house
for free he's living in her house for
free and she's giving him a [ __ ]
allowance basically he's 36 years old 36
and he's living with him he does not
actually honor the system that she
herself guarantees me hey Dayton I know
but you know I actually have a little
bit of patience because you know your
dad's dying of cancer
no that's karma
karma okay
well Dayton I hope you get karma I hope
you get all the Karma I hope you get a a
terminal case of karma yeah I hope you
get brain Karma
and it spreads to the and it spreads and
it becomes lung and lymph node Karma
yeah it'll be the best kind of karma for
you
so I'm keeping this one record this is
24
60 80 100 that's for the first that's
for the last week of October keep in
mind for new listeners that don't know
who he is I always have to give the
weather because there's new people to
listen he's we started watching when he
was 33 he says he's trans but he's never
done any like surgeries or anything the
reason we're calling him he is he refers
himself as he a lot he goes back and
forth so yeah he's all over the place
he's this is just a dude honestly just a
guy in a dress the entire lgbtq
community of Dayton Ohio [ __ ]
handsome we've covered that before they
want nothing to do with him
um he lives with his parents he doesn't
pay any rent and his parents to shut him
up give him a hundred dollars a week to
do laundry and he doesn't do laundry by
the way he won't some weeks he doesn't
do it uh his brother died and he still
calls his brother a skinhead because his
brother would pick on him because he
would be a piece of [ __ ] to his parents
one time his dad bought him Pizza that
he didn't like and he was mad that it
wasn't from the place that he likes you
through a little hissy fit on YouTube
that's a good qrd
20 40 60 80 100 that's for the first
week of
November
20 40. 60 80 100 that's only three
hundred dollars this is the end of the
fourth week imagine being somebody whose
father is dying of cancer and doing this
like he's got to be a sociopath I mean
at least at the at the very least yeah
and horrendous narcissist tenses yes
but look how he writes oh my look at
this font he writes like it's a hostage
negotiation
not hate me she handed me this oh she
she told me that money was on the
kitchen table
and when I picked it up it was all
stacked together I picked it up and I
came upstairs to
uh and he posted the picture uh here so
because I know it's hard to read
um this is what he posted on the fridge
you owe me two weeks pay today that I
worked eating very little this week
you owe me two weeks pay today that I
worked eating very little this week what
does that have to do with your work you
have money go get food there's Health
burritos I didn't bother you because
last weekend was Halloween and I was
busy on my costume
several days
please pay thank you the front door is
kept open during the day with the
screen door open
as well and that kid nearly the cat near
they got out yet again the poor
can't be open the door can't be open
even slightly she pushes it okay so now
this is all about the cat I get it um
so so honestly this this became way more
about the cat at one point I guess
uh count it as I was coming upstairs she
said your mom's probably and this is
just what I'm saying your mom is
probably absent minded on account of her
husband having cancer you know
I I do believe it probably has a lot to
do probably with the cancer this guy's
such a scumbag no she said to me was did
you get your money and that's it that's
all that she said she doesn't say oh you
only yeah but sees the thing with him
he's such a [ __ ] did you get your money
but he he won't tell her yeah but you
gave me the wrong amount
no instead he passive aggressively
because there's a ransom letter on the
[ __ ] refrigerator written in the font
that I think Bray Wyatt used when he was
the fiend
[ __ ] scary writing on the goddamn
just [ __ ] ask
just go hey
uh like like Royce Let's Pretend let's
pretend you owe me 400 bucks okay hey
you got that money homie now you hear me
three there you go real quick just
was it a 400
um you spent 100 on health burrito so I
deducted it on my card you also didn't
work for two and also you didn't work
you haven't been working you haven't
done laundry you've never had a real job
you've never had a real job
you know we're a little short on money
on the count of your dad dying of cancer
eight thousand dollars what was that
no from the memory of him beating me on
a regular basis and now the stress of
not getting paid what I work for in 2020
she skipped uh let's see she skipped
three thousand dollars she did not pay
through who is she YouTube
3 300 give or take and you know when I
get in the money we head to the bank for
the clip Channel now right you know
we're not getting that either thousand
dollars in 2020 and it wasn't because
she was lacking a job in the middle of
pandemic she took advantage of the fact
that everyone was struggling she got
paid the exact same amount of she I've
ever did or whatever she got paid plenty
she went on three vacations during that
while the pandemic was raised oh dear
[ __ ]
this what he's doing is someone's like
those people that were like [ __ ] on
the employees that were shooting on Elon
Musk on Twitter and then being surprised
to get fired you know and had while
there were a discount you know airfare
you know all that discount airfare that
was spreading the virus around she went
on three vacations during that and spent
the money that she owed me even though
she wasn't actually financially you know
what I was thinking because obviously we
don't want to give the link out to the
videos because the internet got set and
then we're gonna lose his stuff yeah and
then we lose our fund but we could
always grab them and maybe for the
locals throw it and put them up on
locals just just locals like for the
locals people wouldn't be a bad idea Raw
videos that would be dope that way you
guys could just [ __ ] have them you
know she wasn't financially stricken
through any of it and she took advantage
of it because she's a hypocrite and a
liar and a scumbag oh she's not paying
me a three thousand dollars from that
and last year she skipped another one
thousand dollars because she skipped
about uh let's see it was uh about four
months I think if I remember writing but
she skipped the entire summer last year
didn't pay me a cent you don't deserve
any money I can't tell you what you
deserve because we're not on Rumble only
but I can't tell you what you do he gets
worse and worse and I could only like
watch so much of him because after a
while it's just
he's insufferable